dans un peu plus de 24 heures
le norway aura quitté normalement le
quai de l'oubli ou havre où il est
amarré depuis octobre 74
l'ex paquebot france qui sera tirée par
un remorqueur de haute mer devrait
arriver samedi ou dimanche à brême
là il sera réparé et transformé selon
les voeux de son propriétaire
l'armateur norvégien kloster pour être
opérationnelle la saison prochaine dans
la mer des caraïbes
c'est du moins ce qui est théoriquement
prévu car deux obstacles doivent être
franchies premièrement l'opération
remorquage
le paquebot est aussi haut que l'arc de
triomphe
sa prise au vent est considérable le
risque d chouman est réel et depuis
plusieurs jours les syndicats français
et la cgt en particulier dénoncent les
risques énormes qu'il n'ya de remorqué
le navire comme une épave en cas de
tempête second obstacle
les syndicats eux mêmes la cgt s'oppose
au départ du norway et on ne sait pas
comment
dans les faits cela peut se traduire
georges séguy a écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander de faire
annuler le départ du paquebot le
secrétaire général de la confédération
ouvrière se déclare je cite scandalisé
que les travaux de transformation du
bâtiment soit confiée à des chantiers
ouest allemand et il demande au
président giscard d'estaing que de
nouvelles mesures soient prises pour le
sa remise en état
dans les installations portuaires du
havre
quoi qu'il en soit le capitaine
norvégien commandant le norway a affirmé
tout à l'heure que le paquebot
appareillerait comme prévu à 14h30
mercredi matin si le temps le permet
jour j moins deux pour le départ de nord
ouest france à franklin base de la cgt
wavre ultimes réunions d'état-major à 15
heures aujourd'hui
trois voitures ont sillonné les rues de
la ville invitant la population à ce
rang de nombreuses demain matin à la
sous-préfecture quai de l'oubli c'est le
folklore les touristes dont les plaques
d'immatriculation étrangères ou
françaises témoigne de l'intérêt que
l'on porte à l'ex france de tous les
coins d'europe envahissez à bord du
paquebot sous l'oeil bienveillant des
policiers marchand de glaces et de
photos ont vu là une occasion de tirer
un profit rappelant leur manière que les
marins et le personnel hôtelier n'ont
pas été les seuls à être victime du
désarmement de france le ministre de
l'intérieur ministre des transports par
intérim a expliqué aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement à propos du
départ de l'ex paquebot france et de son
réaménagement dans un chantier
ouest-allemand s'appuyant sur les deux
éléments qui ont déterminé le choix du
nouveau propriétaire
c'est de dire les meilleurs délais des
travaux et les écarts de prix
considérable et il
monsieur bonnec condamne certaines
interprétations tendancieuses liés à la
transformation du noroît à l'étranger
non seulement écrit-il le gouvernement
n'a cessé de veiller à donner toutes
leurs chances à nos chantiers dans la
compétition mais il vient en outre de
prendre des décisions concrètes de
nature à soutenir l'emploi actuels et
futurs des industries navales à wavre
une question reste pourtant posée selon
le correspondant la région havraise
c'est d'ailleurs celle qui revient le
plus dans les conversations pourquoi un
armateur français ne pourrait pas faire
ce qu'un hors vézien semble pouvoir a
priori réalisé voici un premier élément
de réponse
il tient en un mot rentabilité tout
d'abord les investissements c'est à dire
avant la mise en service du norway h à
80 millions de francs environ
transformation 190 millions c'est un
minimum coût total 270 millions
amortissement annuel 27 millions on
table sur 10 ans de service le norway à
17 ans la durée de vie d'un tel paquebot
est généralement de 25 en dix ans c'est
donc un maximum à ses 27 millions
il faut ajouter 7 millions au titre de
l'entretien coûts annuels 34 millions de
francs au chapitre du coût
d'exploitation pas de chiffres précis
mais on relève une économie de père
lionel l'équipage du france 15 cents
hommes sera ramené à 7 cents à bord du
norway de plus il sera fait appel en
partie à du personnel étranger donc
moins cher une inconnue le prix du
carburant même avec les transformations
entreprises sur le paquebot le fuel
coûtera de plus en plus cher et c'est là
que réside le pari concernant la
rentabilité du nord ouest
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]